[Music]
[Music]
first things first any man here that
wants to walk away can do so knowing
they're the best of us
there's gotta be now there's no ground
support you sustain we're walking out
with make no mistake about it you guys
need to own the fact if we do not have
the flag on our shoulders you cannot go
back to your normal life after tonight
everything we've done for the last 17
years nothing to show for it
you've been shot five times for your
country and you can't even afford to
send your kids to college if we'd
accomplished the things that we've
accomplished in any other profession we
set for life
I'm your master the question is do we
finally get to use our skills for our
own benefit we're gonna get Gabrielle my
team over half he's got over 75 million
dollars in cash if we're not going
forever after you make your move we are
dead
[Music]
you cannot date they will find us
it's always a little hard and you think
it's gonna be
like that
is this not but I stand up for a lot of
people are gonna come so it goes through
you
[Music]
you